I'm really embarrassed to show you this
[Music]
I'm going through old videos and
thinking a lot about the early days of
how I learned to make a video I thought
I would go back and tell you the story
of how I got into video and learned and
eventually started making documentaries
it's more expensive to live in Hong Kong
than anywhere in the world I'm in
Portland Oregon today for 48 hours for
me it all started with a video camera
that my parents had when I was in high
school I would take this video camera
out and make the weirdest most
horrendous looking short films you could
ever imagine this stuff had no body it
had no use it was ugly and story lists
and just really weird 2007 but what it
did is it started to hone a sense of me
looking through a camera pressing record
and then going and editing images
together and I did it a lot I mean when
I was in high school I would film
everything I again had no sense of
purpose or story or anything but
had my hands on a camera
[Music]
this is still her end Asst and like
worthless stuff but like it represents a
kid tinkering with a camera and it
represents a lot of time behind that
camera eventually what happens when you
put a lot of time into gamers you start
to think of experiments little things
you could do to change the big
experiment was when I learned how to
mask is they take two pieces of video
and to cut out one of them and I started
doing these weird experiments where I
cut myself out and like this one with
this water bottle and throwing back and
forth did this in like 2005 and it was
like my first moment where I was like oh
I can composite two pieces of video over
each other I went to college and brought
my parents video camera with me and
continued to make stuff there as well
and that was similar it didn't really
have a lot of story or structure or
purpose but it was still me putting my
hands on a camera and shooting stuff and
then going in editing and
at college I thought maybe I should be a
film major so I enrolled in the intro to
film class which is the prerequisite for
the film program and in that class I was
a bit disillusioned by the fact that we
were talking about theory and history
and critique of film but we weren't
actually making anything I remember
asking in like the second week like so
when are we gonna like make a movie and
they're like oh wait you do that in like
the fourth year in one class you get to
make a movie but I remember just being
so disappointed like wait what that's
what filming school is so after at one
semester of this intro to film class I
dropped out and I was like no I'm gonna
find something else I kind of had this
idea that I needed to grow up and say
okay my dreams of being a filmmaker are
over and I'm just gonna switch to
something more adult that's where
international relations came in I had
gone on to international trips and kind
of caught the bug of travel and I was
like I'll do international relations
kind of give up the film then I got
married to Isabel while I was in college
how's it going dude
[Music]
oh and she was also kind of into video
and film internet and so we ended up
buying our first camera together man
total bummer I actually spent the rest
of that day in Portland recording the
rest of this and even hung out with my
sister who's a self-taught photographer
and she chimed in and the footage got
deleted or something it was all offline
when I went into the project file so I'm
gonna finish it up here we left off I
went to college started tinkering around
with Izzy Izzy and I who you may know is
is I call her Izzy very often speak of
the devil hey yes yep liking it okay All
Right see you soon bye so me and Izzy
during college started to nerd out about
cameras so solids the housing is just so
much more solid and nice compared to our
50 we bought an expensive camera
expensive at the time for us and felt
the need to like get good at it and so
actress started shooting weddings like
photographing weddings which in Utah
it's a really cheap wedding market and
so we were able to like break into it
somehow and it was fun and like we just
got a lot of time to play with our
camera we would do shoots with friends
yeah it was a really good time we
started filming our lives and just for
personal documentation we have all this
old footage that we've edited together
and that was just another era of using a
camera a lot and editing a lot and
around that time I also started to see
on the internet more motion graphics 2d
motion graphics really becoming a thing
like infographics that move and I was
like I wonder if I can learn this and so
I took a tutorial on lynda.com and
essentials training for After Effects
which is the Adobe program that I used
to animate and I loved it I loved it the
problem was my stuff was garbage like a
legit garbage I mean I take a look at
this
[Music]
just like super bad stuff but it started
off this interest rose like I love
making these designs move so I started
playing around and kind of making gummy
projects that I could get some
experience making motion graphics so
during high school during college I had
good amount of experience with playing
around truly playing not really doing
much professional work in video and
later motion graphics how that
transitioned into then a professional
market and a professional job is a story
for another time and I will tell that
story in a video that I'm going to call
how I got my job at box which is another
big question it gets for now I want to
focus on this these early days and give
you my two big takeaways of why I think
this is important to talk about and why
I'm showing you all this old like kind
of ugly looking footage number one you
don't need a gate keeper to validate you
in this industry meaning you don't need
a film school or a certificate or anyone
to say yes you know how to be a
videographer or no you don't know how to
be a videographer or whatever it is you
want to be in this space the skills and
the learning of those skills has been so
democratized in recent years that if you
want to you can become a videographer
and the tools exist through both the
training and the tools like the camera
I'm shooting it out right now it's a
Sony rx100 is literally a
point-and-shoot and it's tiny but I can
make legitimate films on this if I
wanted to and it's a thousand bucks so
the more important lesson here and the
harder one to digest is that these
skills only come through putting in a
lot of time behind this camera there's
no shortcut to that unless you're like
some weird prodigy child which does
exist but the rest of us we have to put
in the time and that time doesn't always
have to be serious and you know what
professional work for a lot of my life
I've been making not serious not even
good work but it was time
was time that I was putting man in the
camera and that counts for something
especially if you approach that time
that large body of time and work as a
time to experiment and play with new
things so find ways to force yourself to
make stuff and that can be documenting
your travels or your family or your
day-to-day life and it doesn't have to
go to a big audience or doesn't even
have to be good okay any other questions
you have leave them here in the
description and I will get to them in
future videos Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
last thing I'll say before I sign up
here is that I am gonna start to send
out an email to people with is every
month that has four things a Spotify
playlist that we're listening to that
month a video that is inspiring us some
piece of content in the world that is
inspiring us that we like and number
four a little update on our lives and
the course that we're doing and stuff
like that so if you're interested in
that go to man where do you go I'll put
the link here in the description for you
to sign up for that
if I don't it's easy you can just go to
is Harris comm she's the only one with a
website right now I'm incredibly anti
marketing emails and so I will promise
you now that we will send one email a
month with a dependable amount of
content you can decide if you want it or
not it and will make it very easy to
unsubscribe if you don't have no
intention of spamming people because I
hate being spammed myself is Harris calm
it's izh ARR is calm and you can send it
for the newsletter thanks guys